So now we know about the when,
what, and how of adaptive design.
Let's look back at those
suboptimal tablet UIs, and
see what we can do to improve them.
So this Gmailesque example previously
let's uncomfortable reading experiences
on wider screens.
We can use the divide pattern to show
message details on larger devices,
to make better use of the space, and
contain either column from becoming
too wide, and uncomfortable to read.
Here we're capping the list
at a maximum width, and
then filling the remaining
space with the message details.
Notice that we are also using the expand
pattern within the message details.
Where it also caps the body
at a maximum width,
to ensure a comfortable reading, by
introducing margins beyond that point.
This adaptation could
also help with context.
We can read a message within
the larger context of other emails.
For example,
seeing if a new message comes in.
If we don't have more
content that we can reveal,
then we can restrict
the width of the surface.
And use generous margins to stop
it from becoming unbalanced.
Before this example felt
unbalanced on larger devices,
leaving large areas of white space.
We can apply the extend pattern,
and introduce this new surface,
to contain the form on larger screens.
We center this surface, and
apply generous margins within it,
to maintain balance.
In our last example, we previously had a
number of issues with unbalanced layout,
overly wide buttons, and
poor use of imagery.
When adapting to wider devices, we can
set a maximum width on the buttons.
And here, we reflow them to the right,
preventing them from
reaching awkward sizes.
We can also use the expand
pattern on the content,
to center on its own surface,
beyond a certain width.
And lastly, we switch to a more
immersive image position,
with the content overlapping it,
to prevent the issues we saw before.